le décor est prêt la commission rouleau
entame 6 semaines d'audience
Paul des organisateurs du convoi de
camionneur sont bien visibles
en lien avec les manifestations promet
d'être là tous les jours elle sera
éventuellement appelée à donner sa
version des faits comme une soixantaine
de témoins incluant des responsables
gouvernementaux des policiers et des
experts
cheveux à l'autre le commissaire cherche
à établir l'effet les audiences
offriront un processus impartial pour
son mandat comprendre pourquoi le
gouvernement fédéral a évoqué les
mesures d'urgence face aux
manifestations
comment il a utilisé ses pouvoirs
spéciaux et si ces actions étaient
appropriées à la fin le commissaire
pourrait recommander des changements à
la loi la tâche et colossale beaucoup de
témoins et des milliers de documents à
analyser tout ça en peu de temps Paul
rouleau déplore l'accès difficile et
tardif au document gouvernementaux bon
nombre de ces documents remis à la
Commission sont classifiés sous réserve
de la sécurité nationale ou d'autres
revendications de privilèges d'entrée de
jeu les avocats des différents
intervenants ont étalé leur position les
mesures d'urgence étaient justifiées
selon ceux du gouvernement fédéral et
wonders
qui évoque une menace à la sécurité du
Canada les conséquences des blocages
illégaux il est intimidation à l'endroit
des résidents d'Ottawa
mais la Police provinciale de l'Ontario
croit au contraire que les pouvoirs
spéciaux étaient superflus et que les
policiers disposaient de tous les outils
pour faire leur travail
les provinces de l'Alberta et de la
Saskatchewan affirme ne pas avoir été
consulté convenablement par Ottawa sur
le recours aux mesures d'urgence telles
que l'exige la loi comme si la décision
était déjà prises
reviendront s'expliquer lors des deux
dernières semaines de Diams en novembre
le commissaire a rappelé que le
gouvernement Trudeau a été le premier à
utiliser la Loi sur les mesures
d'urgence selon lui il y a donc un grand
intérêt public à déterminer si ces
pouvoirs spéciaux ont été utilisés
convenablement ici Louis Blouin
Radio-Canada
Ottawa